tout à l'heure j'ai entendu le mot
laxisme et je voudrais faire une
référence à quelque chose d'actualité
monsieur darmanin quand il a parlé de de
la drogue et des amendes que l'on à
aller donner aux gens qui sont
consommateurs de il a ajouté dans sa
phrase quelque chose qui est un lapsus
extraordinaires y compris dans les beaux
quartiers y compris dans les beaux
quartiers
cela veut dire quoi que avant non avant
non on avait un certain laxisme à
l'égard des beaux quartiers qu'on
traitait pas de la même façon un petit
dealer ou un petit consommateur de
banlieue et des beaux quartiers
j'ai trouvé dans cette phrase un très
joli lapsus
[Musique]